we now have a definite integral going
from x equals zero to x equals square
root of pi of X sine of x squared DX so
the first thing that you might want to
ask yourself is is whether u
substitution is appropriate here and if
it is what would you set u to be equal
to I'll let you think about that for a
second well we see here this expression
x squared and if we were to just take
the derivative of x squared would be 2x
we have an X here so it's almost a 2x to
turn this X into 2x we could multiply it
by 2 we can't just only multiply it by
two because that would change the value
of this entire expression we'd also have
to multiply by 1/2 so all I've done so
far is I multiplied by 2 and by 1/2
which is the same thing as multiplying
by 1 I have not changed the value of
this entire definite integral now let's
do our u substitution if we set u is
equal to x squared u is equal to x
squared we now know that D u D U is
going to be equal to 2x DX and so what
can we see here well we have our u there
that's how we defined it and our D U is
going to be 2x times DX
so this is entire inside or the thing
that we're taking the integral of the
definite integral of is going to be we
can rewrite it as sine sine of x squared
but x squared is just used so sine of U
and instead of 2x DX we know that 2x DX
is now D u D u so the thing that we're
taking the integral of in terms of u can
be expressed this way and so we have our
integral but these boundaries of
integration were written in terms of X
we could have written this as X is equal
to 0 to X is equal to square root of pi
now we want to write them in terms of U
and let me not forget that I had this
1/2 sitting out here so how do we write
it in terms
you so this when X is equal to zero what
is you going to be equal to this
boundary is when x equals zero well when
X is equal to 0 U is also equal to zero
so this is from u equals zero this is
the same boundary when X is equal to 0 U
is equal to zero based on how we defined
you now what about here what is u equal
to when X is equal to the square root of
pi well u is equal to the square root of
pi squared let me write this down
U is going to be equal to is going to be
equal to the square root of pi squared
when X is equal to the square root of Pi
which is just equal to pi so this is
going to be from u equals zero to u
equals pi I didn't have to explicitly
write this u equals here but that makes
a little bit clearer our boundaries are
now written in terms of U and so we are
now ready to we are now ready to
evaluate this indefinite integral so
this whole thing is going to be equal to
one half x times the expression well
what's the antiderivative of sine of U
well the derivative of cosine of U let
me write over here DDX or maybe I should
write in terms of u DD u cosine of U is
equal to negative negative sine negative
sine of u so the derivative derivative
of negative cosine of U is equal to sine
of U is equal to sine of U so the
antiderivative sine of U is negative
cosine of U negative negative cosine u
and we're going to evaluate that from at
U equals PI and from that we're going to
subtract it evaluated at u equals 0 u
equals zero so this is going to be equal
to one half times what what happens when
we evaluated it at u equals pi negative
cosine of PI cosine of PI if we just now
always have to redraw my unit circles
here so cosine of PI where at this point
the unit circle cosine is the
x-coordinate cosine of pi is let me just
write it down it's going to be negative
cosine of pi and then from that we are
going to subtract this evaluated when u
equal zero so minus so minus negative
cosine negative cosine of zero not
cosine of theta that's what it's going
to be equal to and now we're ready to
evaluate it cosine of PI is negative one
then we have this negative out front so
this whole thing will evaluate to 1
cosine of 0 cosine of 0 is 1 and then
we're subtracting a negative 1 which is
the exact same thing as adding a 1 so
this whole thing also becomes a positive
one and so in here we have 1 plus 1
times 1/2 so this whole thing simplifies
to ready for our drum roll 1 and you see
when we did use substitution with a
definite integral as long as we changed
our boundaries in terms of U we didn't
have to go and then undo the
substitution we didn't even have to go
and convert back into X we were able to
evaluate the definite integral in terms
of U